welcome back to New rockstars I'm Eric
Boss and the biggest mystery of Ant-Man
in the WASP Quantum media is what the
[ __ ] is guanamania other than a thematic
reference to the quantum realm and that
joke in the 2018 film about everyone
putting the word Quantum in front of
everything it looks like the deeper
meaning of the term quantumania is being
left a mystery for now similar to how
the title of Thor love and thunder was a
mystery revealed only in the final line
of that movie Thor loved to fit another
Hemsworth on the payroll I believe the
secret meaning of quantum media is also
being kept Under Wraps as a title with
some surface level marketability to give
us an idea of the movie but possessing a
deeper connection to the characters and
the narrative so that when it's spoken
aloud everyone in the audience will go
oh yeah that's the name of the movie One
interpretation is that Quantum media is
just the name of the quantum realm
civilization where Kang has constructed
his militarized City based on the bubble
design of the city's exterior in the
background of the quantum realm and the
2018 film it seems like the studio wants
the city to at least somewhat be based
on chronopolis hang City in the comics
chronopolis in the comics is not located
in in the comics equivalent of the
quantum realm that's the microverse
chronopolis is in a Time independent
space called Limbo but in these movies
Marvel is using Quantum Romas both a
subatomic realm and a realm with these
time vortexes and if the city is named
quantumania you would think this trailer
would include someone saying welcome to
quantumania or one of those misguided
screw heads shouting quantumania forever
before one of his friends grabs him and
it's like dude no no don't no I think
the answer to what Quantum media really
refers to is actually hidden in this
shot it's perhaps the most bizarre two
seconds of the trailer Scott Lang is
running in this red Dome beside a larger
Ant-Man who unravels but not his helmet
while dozens or hundreds of more Ant-Man
run around too you can actually see far
more of this shot in the IMAX trailer
there are indeed countless other Scots
in this area and most insanely as the
other one unravels the sky closest to us
begins to split into two so it may be
that all of these Ant-Man in the shot
were actually spawned from one original
Scott and he's kind of the Scott Prime
now could this all be an Illusion by
Kang to torture Scott it does remind us
a lot of that illusion Montage Mysterio
Put Peter Parker through and Spider-Man
far from home which did involve Peter
being attacked by several doppelgangers
of himself but I don't think these in
quantumania are Illusions because Kang
isn't really the type of villain who's
psychologically torture people with
smoke and mirrors at least not after
he's already revealed himself I think
what we are looking at is a physical
example of quantum entanglement the
phenomenon discussed in the 2018 film
that telepathically connected Scott with
Janet it was described by Bill Foster in
his lecture in a stable phase
relationship if the system is interfered
with that stability becomes chaos
isolated completely a Quantum system
would revert back to separate states of
matter in other words the object in
question would be both in and out of
phase with multiple parallel realities
and then afterwards in his office Foster
explained how quantum entanglement
worked with Scott which is indirectly
how we got the title for this movie it's
incredible you're linked to Janet it's
quantum entanglement between the quantum
states of Posner molecules in your
brains do you guys just put the word
Quantum in front of everything does this
moment with Scott and the red Dome not
look like what Bill Foster described an
object both in and out of phase with
multiple parallel realities we are
seeing the Multiverse on a subatomic
scale as a realm as opposed to a
universe the quantum realm show there's
a border with every Universe in the
Multiverse and I think this red area is
kind of Schrodinger's Forge from which
endless variant universes spawn now
Scott's quantum entanglement led to its
Consciousness being linked with Janet's
she used him as a kind of conduit to
speak to Hank and with hope and later
you remember Hank pym's mind briefly
linked with Janet when he found her in
the quantum realm all the trippy visuals
he saw inside that house that was
quantum entanglement and here in this
movie Scott Lang's quantum entanglement
will tangle him up with his variants
that could be why this movie chooses
that unraveling aesthetic like two
Loosely coiled phone charger cables in
your carry-on bag the more unraveled
these get the easier it is for things to
get entangled with each other hey can we
talk Panda van just for a second Marvel
is fantastic and all but sometimes when
I'm on the go I don't want to be blaring
the latest MCU release from my phone on
the subway I just want a curated
collection of my favorite Marvel heroes
well collector's assemble with Marvel
collect by tops you can build the
ultimate Marvel collection get cards
with the Avengers X-Men Guardians of the
Galaxy and more you get free cards in
coins just by logging in Daily or spin
that wheel and get free cards or coins
every time to complete sets and missions
put your favorite collectibles in your
profile and choose an avatar to show off
what kind of Marvel fan you really are
to get started with Marvel collect by
tops just click the link in the
description below to download it today
so how does that answer what quantumania
is I think quantumania is the solution
to the problem of quantum entanglement
it's a running joke now that Scott has a
bug themed Adventure gets compared a lot
to Spider-Man the cafe owner mixes them
up thank you Spiderman an Infinity War
Bruce Banner was even confused by the
two of them there's an Ant-Man and a
Spiderman but I think there are lessons
Ant-Man should learn from Spider-Man no
way home proved that Spider-Man is a
uniquely multiversal being yes every
person has multiversal variants but
Peter Parker is linked to his variants
through their Collective Spider Sense
the spider sense is a supernatural
arachno frequency that originates from
the web of life and Destiny it links all
Peter Parker's and Miles Morales When
Stacy Miguel everybody and no way home
these Peters were in a way entangled
getting mixed up with the same gestures
when Ned called to them initially
tangling up at each other's webs outside
the Statue of Liberty and all getting a
synchronized spider sense when the
Multiverse Men first arrived at the
Statue of Liberty and if you think about
it Scott Lang benefits from a very
similar multiversal hive mind through
his quantum entanglement just like the
hive mind he shares with his aunts in
this High mind that Scott Lang shares
with his variants in the quantum realm I
believe will be what this movie refers
to as quantumania quantumania is Scott
Lang's hive mind with his other variants
when Peter Parker calls Spider Sense and
the way that Spider Sense links him with
his variants this is why Kang the
Conqueror is being introduced in an
Ant-Man movie not because Kang needs
Scott to steal something that was taken
from him and Scott is the mcu's expert
thief but really because Kang's biggest
weakness is his inability to cooperate
he remains explained that soon after all
Kang variants met each other one began
to exploit the others or the others
begin to suspect that someone else would
exploit them and the mutual Trust apps
and they begin to try to conquer each
other Kang does not get along with his
variants the Kang variants hate each
other they mentally block each other out
if you've seen a lot of my Marvel
theories you know that my broader theory
is that everyone in the MCU is either a
dancer or a non-dancer the Drax Theory
dancers know how to work with their
variants across the Multiverse
non-dancers work alone and that will be
the key to defeating this Kang and any
other Kang variant The Avengers come
across through King Dynasty and Secret
Wars trust your hive use your web or use
your ant colony to outnumber and
overwhelm your opponent Quantum area I
mean Kang already signaled a blind spot
by asking Scott haven't I killed you
before this proves that there are so
many Ant-Man he'll never be able to kill
them all and if you need need further
proof that quantumania is inextricably
linked with ant-man's identity you
literally cannot spell the word
quantumania without Ant Man it's
literally Ant-Man with a u in the middle
right there in front of us the whole
time the whole time what do you think
quantumania means follow me on Tick Tock
Instagram and Twitter at eat a boss
follow me rockstars And subscribe to new
rockstars for more analysis of
everything you love thanks for watching
bye
[Music]